foreign
86 to 89 fun with you this morning I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's February 20th 2023 and the team has
just laid out a very difficult High bar
for me to reach today right before we
started I often ask them how do you feel
the show is going to be today uh Phoenix
without hesitation nine eight nine eight
and we're out of ten here over over here
people okay even right there I fumbled
the word we I don't know that I can do
better than a 99 now I'm already screwed
before we get to anything we have a
tremendous show for you today and I'm
like I'm in a good mood I'm rested over
the weekend Oh I should tell you guys
also the kids are doing much better uh
Justin and Luke both had covid okay
David also has covet I think still does
he's still a little little headache a
little snipply whatever but the guys are
doing much better a lot a lot of snot
sucking this weekend it's gross it's
really disgustingly gross have you guys
seen that in the house downstairs the
snot suckers they're horrible um anyway
everybody's doing much better before we
get to the show though so
um in the community and the Reuben
report locals Community Elizabeth made
me this this is little mini Dave that
she crocheted it's technically known as
an Ami gurami I think I'm pronouncing
that right am I pronouncing that right
Ami gurami yeah so we have a little
amigurami little Dave here and uh very
exciting and his jacket even comes off I
mean she did like an absolutely
incredible job Elizabeth just amazing uh
as always guys we got a post game show
for you at the end if you want to join
us reubenreport.locals.com and really
what I want to do today is uh I'm gonna
destroy a couple people
because a couple people need to be
destroyed Don Lemon I mean he's
self-emulating he's lighting himself on
fire but we're just going to push that a
little bit it's just these corporate
hack journalists I just can't take it
anymore I cannot take it any more have
to destroy him the one that I really
have to go after though uh is Andrea
Mitchell over at uh NBC and MSNBC who
had the most ridiculous dishonest
interview with Kamala Harris lying
absolutely 100 percent without
equivocation lying about what Ron
DeSantis is doing here with that now
Infamous AP American studies course and
uh and of course Andrea Mitchell lies
about it which means the producers lie
about it and I would argue at this point
whether you are a network executive over
at the view which I often talk about uh
or you're a network executive over at
CNN or MSNBC or any of these places your
job is actually to hire people to do the
Dirty Work the line for you so they put
Don Lemon out there knowing that his his
job is to lie we'll get to some of his
lies they put Andrea Mitchell out there
for one purpose only like I don't think
Andrew Mitchell is an idiot I don't
think she didn't know what really is
going on with that AP course and that
they're jamming gender studies and other
woke nonsense in there but she is paid
to lie and the question is who is paying
her right like the net the the producer
of that show of that segment should be
fired too so I'm going to call for a
couple people to be fired and I want to
be clear this is not cancel culture
cancel culture is an amorphous mob
unjustly coming for somebody online
because they said something they don't
like when journalists who are supposed
to be the last Bastion defending Freedom
shining a light on the injustices of a
society when they go out of their way to
do the reverse of Journalism in total
dereliction of their Duty they deserve
to be fired so Andrea Mitchell I just
don't think she's an idiot she's been
doing this for 30 some odd years at NBC
so she went into that interview either
so I mean the options we'll get to the
segment in just a sec either the options
are when they do these things where they
know they're lying they're complete
idiots and I just don't think they're
complete idiots they're absolute Liars
or they don't know what they're doing or
they're paid to do it it's or maybe like
a little combination of those four
things something like that anyway
between lemon and Andrea Mitchell we're
going to show you some Gavin Newsom
dishonest stuff and yeah even Trump it's
like I think people have had just enough
of the Endless dishonesty and we have to
get to something better and I think
we're on the cusp of it I really really
do uh and our great Governor you know
about this Rhonda said this guy he's
actually in New York right now
laying out a blueprint to help the blue
States uh curb in some of their crime
because crime obviously running rampant
in New York at Cali and Illinois and a
bunch of other places so that Florida
blueprint that I'm always talking about
is actually being exported right uh as
we're speaking I mean he's doing a press
conference I think right now we already
got some video that we'll show you in
just a little bit that was the longest
intro I've ever given to a show so let's
get cracking uh first off is you may
remember this uh we didn't get a chance
to play it on this show but wanted to uh
get to it today Don Lemon who as you
guys know he was the host of Don Lemon
tonight on CNN nobody was watching he
was sort of just the worst sort of
pandering partisan hack you could be
constantly saying he was a journalist
but then always giving you opinion
that's the reverse of what I do I am not
a journalist I am giving you my opinion
I suppose somehow this has become
journalism but that's a story for
another day uh Don Lemon then got the
boot because nobody was watching his
nighttime show so don't really fire you
in these things they let you keep the
grift going cash the checks a little bit
longer they threw him to the morning
show and now the morning show nobody's
watching that and he's just become a
complete Lampoon of himself and here he
is this is Thursday I'm sure most of you
have seen the clip already but we've got
a couple subsequent things after Don
Lemon saying that Nikki Haley is not in
her prime because she ain't 35. this
solid talk about age makes me
uncomfortable I think that I think it's
the wrong road to go down she says
people you know politicians are
something and not in their Prime Nikki
Haley isn't in a prime sorry when a
woman is considered being her Prime in
her 20s and 30s and maybe 40s that's not
according to me Prime for what it
depends I mean it's just like Prime if
you look it up it'll if you look if you
Google when is a woman in a prime it'll
say 20s 30s and 40s I don't know 40s I'm
not saying I agree with that so I think
she has to be careful about saying that
you know politicians aren't in their
privacy are you talking about Prime for
like child preparing or are you talking
about
the facts are Google and everybody at
home when is a woman in her prime it
says 20s 30s and 40s and I'm just saying
Nikki Haley should be careful about
saying that politicians are not in their
Prime and they need to be in their Prime
when they serve because she wouldn't be
in a prime according to
Google Google or whatever it is all
right so look we don't have to bellay
everybody the point on this clown Don
Lemon is a clown like he's just a clown
he is an actor LARPing as a person who's
supposed to be a news anchor that's all
he's going to get fired soon so we can
limit the amount of damage extra damage
I'm gonna do to him today Don and I also
were friends at some period and then he
just kind of went off the rails is what
it is doesn't matter but this idea that
women are somehow in their Prime and 20s
and 30s and 40s and that Nikki Haley was
somehow that she should be careful when
saying that is so crazy because first
off he would have never said that about
Hillary Clinton right Hillary Clinton
what is she now she's got to be 70 at
this point right she's 70 72 something
like that um he would have never said it
about her but her Point really was that
there's a difference between being 45 55
even 65 and being 80 82 you are clearly
no longer in your Prime Hillary Clinton
is 75 years old like she's you're not
the the truth is you're not in your
Prime at that point but he's making this
into some weird sexist whatever anyway
you can see these two women sitting
across him it's like lemon are you in
your Prime you're you're a 56 year old
you know soon to be unemployed news
anchor would you say you're in your
Prime anyway here's the next morning on
CNN
I have serious fomo from that interview
that Poppy Dan jealous poppy is at NBA
All-Stars weekend it is going to be so
good we have so many good moments from
that including that full interview there
good morning everyone Audi cordesh is
here at the desk with us this morning
Don has the day off no that was not Don
Lemon in drag that was ADI Cornish right
over there and that was Friday they sent
him packing on vacation and then look
what happened this morning
[Music]
good morning everyone we do begin with
breaking news this morning President
Biden makes a surprise visit to Ukraine
I'm Poppy Harlow in New York here with
Sarah seidner Caitlin Collins is live in
Warsaw Poland where the president will
be shortly Don has the day off and here
is what we know right now
John's got the day off again lemon it's
almost like you're not in your Prime and
you need more days off than the average
person so where did Don Lemon go
you're not going to believe it guys
Miami that's right he's in my city right
now you could be wandering down the
beach and see Don Lemon come look at
that we're so did he pose for that
picture like what anyway of course of
course he comes to Florida after bashing
Ron DeSantis and bashing all the crazy
right-wingers in their mean and they're
racist and they don't like gay people
where does he go he goes to the mean gay
gay hating place called Florida to swim
in our oceans he's staying at a two
thousand dollar a night hotel by the way
so he's doing just fine uh I don't mean
to rub salt in the wound of lemon other
than the fact that this is a guy who was
sort of sane and that's one of the odd
things that you find about so many of
these media people you can always point
but not always but within reason you
could usually point to a moment where
they were saying and then it's like how
do they all go off the rails the way
that they do right where then they're
just calling half the country racist and
bigoted in homophobes and they hate
women and they hate old people all of
the nonsense that he puts forth we found
this video this is from 10 years ago
we're going to split it into two parts
for you ten years ago 2013. listen to
Don Lemon talking about five things that
could fix the black community and tell
me if this sounds like uh Don Lemon in
2023 or did something happen to him over
the course of these last 10 years
because black people if you really want
to fix the problem here's just five
things that you should think about doing
here's number five and if if this
doesn't apply to you if you're not doing
this then it doesn't apply to you I'm
not talking about you here's number five
pull up your pants walking around with
your ass and your underwear showing is
not okay in fact it comes from prison
when they take away belts from The
Prisoner so that they can't make a
weapon and then it evolved into which
role a prisoner would have during male
on male Prison Sex the one with the
really low pants is a submissive one
you get my point
number four now is the n-word
by promoting the use of that word when
it's not germane to the conversation
have you ever considered that you may
just be perpetuating The Stereotype the
master intended acting like
now number three respect where you live
start small by not dropping trash
littering in your own communities I've
lived in several predominantly white
neighborhoods in my life I rarely if
ever witness people littering I live in
Harlem now it's an historically black
neighborhood every single day I see
adults and children dropping their trash
on the ground when a garbage can is just
feet away
just being honest here
I am lemon out there sounded like Larry
Elder and Thomas Soul what but that's
lemon 10 years ago so uh pick up your
pants first off I did not know about
that uh situation in the men's prisons I
watch Orange is the New Black that was a
woman's prison
they're up to some scary stuff over
there I did not know the other thing uh
but anyway pick up your pants okay this
sounds like Jordan Peter Peterson stuff
right wear clothes that fit shocking say
the N word a little bit less okay I
think we can all get on board that one
uh respect where you live and lemon
makes a point of saying he's lived
around a lot of white people my God is
there anyone more assimilated living
with black people than white people
living together cats and dogs it's crazy
he continued
number two finish school you want to
break the cycle of poverty stop telling
kids are acting white because they go to
school or they speak proper English a
high school dropout makes on average
nineteen thousand dollars a year a heist
a high school graduate makes twenty
eight thousand dollars a year a college
graduate makes fifty one thousand
dollars a year over the course of a
career a college grad will make nearly a
million dollars more than a high school
graduate that's a lot of money and
number one and probably the most
important just because you can have a
baby it doesn't mean you should
especially without planning for one or
getting married first more than 72
percent of children in the
African-American Community are born out
of wedlock that means absent fathers and
the studies show that lack of a male
role model is an Express train right to
prison and the cycle continues I think
you guys see what I'm trying to do here
the guy was saying now I don't know how
that is considered journalism that's his
opinion on all of those things but that
used to be something that could air on
CNN I believe at that point he was a
daytime host if I'm not mistaken then he
got promoted to Prime Time now he's uh
in the morning so he's kind of been all
over the place in that regard
um but that that's clearly opinion and
by the way all the networks they do
opinion Tucker is doing an opinion show
not a straight up news show but lemon
always says that he's a journalist
that's that's the different thing but
basically pull up your pants don't say
the n-word respect where you live finish
school and don't have a baby out of
wedlock that is Larry Elder stuff that
is Jordan Peterson's stuff that is
Thomas solstap actually it's it's basic
Common Sense take care of your get
yourself in order and then see what
happens and and if you do that if you
clean your room you might be able to
clean the world but you got to do it in
that order but that's the type of dare I
say conservative stuff that Don Lemon
used to say although here he is talking
about BJs
lied to him and said I have an infection
and if you rape me or if you do if you
have intercourse with me then you will
probably get it and give it to your wife
right you said he would he made you
perform oral sex right
you
you know there are ways not to perform
oral sex if you oh
um I was kind of stoned at the time and
quite honestly that didn't even enter in
my mind
now I wish it would have
right but meaning the using of the teeth
right yes that's what I'm thinking
you're yeah I didn't even think of it
biting so um yes
the using of the teeth
I just sounded like Bill Cosby when I
said the using of the teeth you see I'm
trying to drug you
so I can get a and the using of
the teeth
um that quote though
this should be done done if you're
watching this show and maybe I'll see
you in Miami today I'm going to be out
about this afternoon uh but for your
next book man the title there it's this
is it there are ways not to perform oral
sex by Don Lemon that is a book I would
buy that book it's an incredible book
and you list 10 ways not to give oral
sex anyway he says this to this woman
absolutely insane but if you think
that's nuts if you if you think that's
nuts we've got another clip for you you
see here's Don Lemon in 2021 telling
Chris Cuomo that Trump voters are evil
on vaxers are evil and stupid and morons
and the rest of it here we go I think we
have to stop coddling people when it
comes to this and the vaccine saying oh
you can't shame them you can't call them
stupid you can't call them still again
yes they are the people who ate and
abetted Trump are stupid because they
believed his big lie the people who are
not getting vaccines who are believing
the lies on the internet instead of
science it's time to start shaming now
what else or leave them behind that
really was the clip that made me want to
do this thing because Don should be
shamed right someone who is not vaxxed
who had vaccine hesitancy who actually
maybe took care of themselves and ate
right and was in good shape and got some
sunshine and everything else or did
whatever decision they wanted to do
regarding their own health should not be
shamed by a ridiculous again
quote-unquote journalist on CNN right
and all the people if they voted for
Trump and believe Trump I mean they're
stupid all of those things and then it's
just hilarious because Chris Cuomo
stepped down in shame the guy he's
talking to and lemon is about to be
fired anyway here's one more 11. man we
are really when life gives you lemons
make
internet videos I don't know something
um here's one more 11. this is him last
week he had this guy on Bishop mckissick
uh talking about Ron DeSantis and
education because as you guys know I
will clearly state it one more time uh
Ron DeSantis removed an APM
African-American studies course from
Florida curriculum where they were going
to teach critical race Theory and they
were going to teach woke gender nonsense
and all of these things as it relates to
African-American studies that's what he
removed he did not remove anyone any
high school or college class from
teaching about civil rights or Martin
Luther King or slavery or the Civil War
or anything else but lemon has Bishop
mckissick on to talk about just that and
Bishop you're going to this protest
today what is what is the biggest
message the clearest line that you want
to get across by going and attending
well we wanted to be very clear that we
are not here just to make a statement
but we're here to affect a change
Governor DeSantis says they want
education and not indoctrination and we
want to be very clear to not miss the
forest because of the trees this is not
just about an AP course this is also
about his attempt to dilute uh Colleges
and Schools teach diversity equity and
inclusion and it is our attempt to say
we will not allow you to redact our
history whitewash our history because in
doing that you are left with nothing but
a conservative Consciousness and thought
about black history which in effect is
indoctrination so we're not the ones
doing the indoctrinating he is the one
that's doing it that's what I'm going to
say that you know the whole idea of the
history that many of us were taught
growing up and you know Christopher
Columbus discovered America which sort
of
if you all need to rub your temples
right now I know it's Monday you enjoyed
yourself over the weekend hopefully you
come back you go is it still happening
is it still happening and it is still
happening everything that the bishop
said there is nonsense DeSantis is
defending from the indoctrination the
indoctrination is diversity equity and
inclusion and the rest of this woke
drivel and all of the gender stuff that
they are putting in the schools so
DeSantis is just saying hey how about we
go back to the stuff we were teaching
say five or seven or ten years ago no
one in Florida was not you think of the
average kid in Florida was not learning
about Civil Rights was not learning
about uh Martin Luther King and all the
rest of it like of course they were and
do you think honestly really guys think
about it for one second and this is when
you're brainwashed NPC friends come up
to you and they go oh my God you had
Rhonda Santa see nothing like black
people
I made them sound like that uh whatever
um when they do that to you well that is
what they all sound like at the end of
the day actually when they do that to
you you have to say to them do you
honestly think that in Florida they are
not allowed to teach about civil rights
do you honestly think that if a teacher
gives an honest assessment of what
Martin Luther King's life was all about
that that he is going to be fired it's
so beyond the pale but these people love
the lies and they love the lies because
they're constantly being fed the lies so
they are addicted to the lies it's the
only thing that they know so this guy
gets on there this bishop gets on there
and says that diversity Equity inclusion
is an honest assessment of black history
but no it is not the Civil Rights
Movement the March towards equality not
Equity is the actual history Martin
Luther King himself would be embarrassed
and ashamed by what BLM and the woke
activists have become because it's
counter to what he wanted where he
wanted his kids not to be judged by the
color of their skin but by the content
of their character director so these
people have everything backwards lemon
is just placating it so let me
officially say because I'm going to go
for a couple people here Don Lemon
should be fired it's not because he's an
idiot it's not because he's buffoon it's
not because he's an actor it's because
he is flat out terrible at his job now I
get it the network Executives hired him
to be terrible at his job so a couple of
them should probably be fired too but
these people are actually doing damage
to America at this point they are part
of a brainwashing organization that
clearly is designed to make people
stupid it is it is designed to keep one
set of ideas in power and make sure that
everyone who challenges that is somehow
considered a bad guy or a right-wing
Maniac or something like that so let's
move lemon to the side okay and let's
talk about Andrea Mitchell this one is
really incredible Andrea Mitchell has
been a journalist on NBC and MSNBC and a
bunch of other places she's not Meet the
Press all the time
she goes she gets major major interviews
she goes to all of the presidential
debates etc etc she is thought of as a
mainstream non-partisan journalist okay
here she is sitting down with Kamala
Harris talking about what Ron DeSantis
is doing with these AP courses now
listen to the way she frames the
question now you just have to think
before we show you the clip does Andrea
Mitchell have no idea what she's talking
about or is she a paid activist to push
a certain point of view and then you
just you're saying it's a Kamala who has
about two neurons firing so a lot of
dribble at her go what does Governor Ron
DeSantis not know about about black
history and the black experience when he
says that
slavery and the aftermath of slavery
should not be taught to Florida school
children I don't know what he knows and
what he doesn't know but I know this
any push to censor
America's teachers
and tell them what they should be
teaching in the best interest of our
children
in
in partnership with the parents of
America is I think wrong-headed
the people who know our children best
are their parents and their teachers in
terms of the time they spend and the
investment they've placed in the brains
and capacity
of our children who are our nation's
future and
it should not be some politician
saying what should be taught in our
classrooms
it's so incredible Kamala is just an
idiot so I don't even know that I can
deal with her man I'm fired up on this
Monday morning
it's because I'm running an infirmary
all weekend I haven't spoke to an adult
in a while it's good to see you guys
look Kamal is just an idiot everything
she says there if you believed any of
that Kamala you would be for school
choice right it shouldn't be politicians
who tell kids what to do except you and
the Democrats are the ones that want all
of the kids going to public schools so
that they can be brainwashed by your
teachers unions and everything else so
she's just a Mindless before let's just
move her aside Andrea Mitchell what an
insane what an insane way of framing
this what does Rhonda santis not know
about the black experience something to
that effect what a crazy way why does he
not want slavery and the aftermath of
Slavery to be taught
it is a complete lie so you must
understand these people that work at NBC
News the the segment producer you have
to be fired somebody has to be fired if
we're to believe that any of this means
anything now I get it there again
they're not in the business of Truth
they are not in the business of anything
honest they are in the business of
propaganda so when I say that they
should be fired I understand no one's
going to be fired but Andrea Mitchell
should be shamed everywhere she goes
because again either she's an idiot so
she's asking questions of which she
knows nothing about or she is paid the
segment producer and the producer above
that and the EP is a whole machine at
NBC news they are literally paying them
to lie so that Kamala Harris who's a
can lie in her response but they
launder the lies together as I often say
so it continues not just on NBC but on
their junior Network MSM you see that
televised mental institution here's Joy
Reed and David jolly and this guy am I
correct this guy is a congressman in
Florida David Jolly he's a is he a
Florida Congressman I want to get this
right before we start he has a Floridian
Congressman Jesus Christ you see we've
got our own problems here here they are
uh talking about Governor DeSantis and
again getting rid of woke gender
ideology from one African-American
studies course but look at what they
extrapolate out of that because what
they're doing with all of these memes
and schtick is they're kind of softening
up the electorate for some really
bizarre things that they want to do
Banning lgbtq books Nationwide that's
big big government
yeah it would be funny if it wasn't so
dangerous because they are in power and
they might have even more power in 2024
look on on immigration this is a party
whose most recent achievement was to
separate innocent children from their
parents many of those kids never to be
reunited again and that is actually a
policy they would likely pursue on this
Banning books issue and I've got to say
it's not just Marjorie Taylor green and
George Santos it is Ron DeSantis and
other governments break down the
absurdity and I honestly think you got
to attack the absurdity of it first and
foremost this is a group of people I
believe reading a book can make you gay
think about it that that's their biggest
concern if you read a book you might
decide you're gay they think the
solution to what they see as societal
ills is big big government it's the
governor of Florida telling you
specifically what books you can read
it's the government deciding
specifically what teachers can teach
it's literal government thought control
this is incredible this is this is
absolutely incredible today is it
because it's a Monday it's a Monday
thing or something like that every
single thing that they say is alive they
love big government control okay first
off the guy's a former Congressman so
that makes me feel good David Jolly is a
former Republican congressman who now
goes on MSNBC tells you all need all you
need to know about this guy okay so
let's uh let's just move past uh Mr
Jolly there uh the books that they are
referring to no one thinks that the book
is going to make you gay you morons what
they don't want is in many of these
books they are literally teaching kids
what apps to download to go have
anonymous sex with strangers and how to
give hand jobs and and I
suppose if you were going to have that
book in the class you could also have
Don lemon's book there are ways not to
perform oral sex by Don Lemon I suppose
if they put both of those books together
then we'd have an actual functioning
library with a diverse set of ideas but
everything they say is a Lie the state
is in control of what books you can read
that is how it works so generally
conservatives and Republicans want more
school choice for some reason these
people want pornographic books in the
kindergartens I don't know why that
would be something to ask them but what
else do they do on the mainstream media
and you can see it's happening and this
was obvious that it was going to happen
and that's why I've been talking about
it for so long and why I think we have
to prepare ourselves accordingly The
Assault on truth is here at a steroidal
bananas level at this point and what
it's really coming down to is there is
one guy who is leading the attack
against it there is one guy who is
saying no from a government perspective
and it's DeSantis and he's doing it
better than anybody so what is the media
going to do not only are they going to
lie
about everything that he says but they
will also bring on a certain set of
Republicans to tell you how bad and mean
and scary he is this is what they used
to do with never Trump Republicans these
were people who had never accomplished
any well men I was going to say many of
them have never accomplished anything in
their lives these are the David from
types these are the neocon types who got
us into all sorts of Wars have all sorts
of death on their hands but they always
had to make it seem like they were the
principled Republicans and Donald Trump
is sort of orange and he eats McDonald's
and he has steak with ketchup and he's
very mean and scary uh and they never
accomplish anything they never conserve
anything and you can already see this
all of them are now becoming rapidly
anti-desantis because again DeSantis
they will describe him as Hitler with a
calculator because he's competent but
there is nothing the media loves more
than a republican who will take out an
effective Republican Q former Maryland
governor Larry Hogan uh here he is he's
getting all the Press now nobody
supports this guy he has no interesting
ideas no one will vote for him but they
really we want to push him as a viable
candidate because he will be an impotent
Republican and he'll do whatever he can
to get on TV to take out DeSantis
question to you is not whether this is a
legitimate issue to be talking about
it's about whether this is the main
issue or not do you view this as the
main issue for 2024 no I think it's an
important issue and I do hear it and
people are concerned about this as I
travel around the country because you
know most people just don't think we
should be talking about you know things
like sex to young kids and the parents
want to be more involved in this
decisions about what their kids are
being taught however you know I think
some of this rhetoric is uh you know
some you know demanding that things be
done a certain way or that you can't say
this you can't say that we've got to be
really careful no does it feel like
you're going the other way like it's
sort of like you're on one hand if
Governor DeSantis claiming hey I don't
want all of this but I'm going to tell
you exactly what you can say and I'm
going to tell you what you can't say
well I'm a small government you know
Common Sense conservative and to me it
sounds like big government and
authoritarian uh you have to agree with
me and I'm going to tell you what you
can and can't do so but it's an issue
it's not the most important issue I
think more people are concerned learned
about the economy inflation they're
concerned about crime but education is
one of the things that we've got to talk
about I'm sorry do we have a bleeper am
I able to are you able to bleep me in
any way all right I'm going to curse
guys I'm going crazy this morning I
cannot believe this is real I don't know
if there was maybe crack in my coffee or
something but these people like
what the enough enough of the
lies everything they're saying there is
a lie and parents do care and nobody
wants this and and you Larry Hogan Larry
Hogan I had him on the show he came to
my house when we lived in La I had him
on the show he was a decent guy that was
about four or five years ago something
like that we agreed to go have
Margaritas in Annapolis that's what we
were going to do because I knew of a
little Mexican joint right there in
Annapolis right on the main thing they
got those good fish tacos over there but
he is an absolute clown and he is being
propped up by a system that will do
anything to make sure that anyone who is
effective at telling you the truth will
be destroyed and that's why they're all
going after DeSantis DeSantis is not
telling anyone what they can say or
can't say he doesn't want third graders
learning how to give hand jobs
I wanted to be a respectable member of
the community you know what I mean
that's all I wanted years ago
anyway here's Gavin Newsom he's a
horrible person he's a lizard he is a
lizard who much like Buffalo Bill in
Silence of the Lambs skins people and
puts on a human skin outfit over his
lizard skin and then pretends to be a
human now fortunately for us as you know
in Silence of the Lambs Buffalo Bill was
stopped by Clarice Starling right before
he was able to put on the women's suit
okay put the lotion in the basket you
all know that Gavin Newsom has somehow
been able to put the human skin suit
over his lizard body and and become
governor of California here he is going
off on DeSantis too you need to get
aggressive I mean why are we on the
defense reacting to Ron DeSantis I want
to wake people up to what the hell's
going on the rights that we've fought so
hard for the last half century being
rolled back in real time this rights
regression is real civil rights you know
voting rights gay lesbian bisexual
transgender rights what's happened with
contraception abortion these guys are
claiming Freedom they're banning books
Banning private speech not just public
free speech attacking the Special
Olympics National Hockey League you saw
the College Board roll over to DeSantis
that means it's the rank racism the
other ring the demeaning of vulnerable
people Democrats need to wake up we're
not on the offense we're sitting here
playing defense saying perhaps we are
too woke
yes you are too woke you stole this
little monster
um everything he said there was a lie do
we need to go into all of it
um he stopped the NHL hockey thing from
coming to Florida because they were
going to ban white kids who wanted to
play we've already made the point about
what's going on at the schools every
single thing he said there was a lie
Gavin Newsom is evil he is evil and
soulless and we must understand that by
the way nearly a million people it's
going to cross a million any day now
have left California since covid started
so a million really think about what a
million people is
there are a million Souls that left
California because they could not deal
with the from that lizard man
okay and you know where they moved they
moved to Florida Florida right now still
getting 1200 people per day per day we
cannot build fast enough because we are
taking in refugees from Lizard Man Okay
uh here's Lizard Man back in July going
off on DeSantis again it's Independence
Day so let's talk about what's going on
in America Freedom it's under attack in
your state Republican leaders they're
banning books making it harder to vote
restricting speech in classrooms even
criminalizing women and doctors I urge
all of you living in Florida to join the
fight or join us in California where we
still believe in freedom freedom of
speech freedom to choose freedom from
hate and the freedom to love don't let
them take your freedom paid for by
Newsome for California Governor 2020
I could see how what's his name uh Bruce
Banner would lose control and the Hulk
would just explode out of him you know
what I mean he's doing those breathing
exercises all day and then he watches
the Gavin Newsom Hulk smash
um okay again everything he said they're
criminal yes we're criminalizing women
and doctors here I was actually walking
my dog this morning and there were there
were giant uh trucks with desantis's
face on the side and they were grabbing
women off the street
oh
um actually you know who is
criminalizing doctors it's Gavin Newsom
uh he pushed for a law to be passed
related to disinformation and
misinformation on the covid vaccine so
that doctors who'd go against what the
state of California wants meaning if
they're vaccine Skeptics they could
actually have their license taken away
we did find this one on the interwebs
this is a here finally and I need
something to just I need to be able to
relax for just a moment a humorous
version of a Gavin newsoman over the
last few years a redwood forests have
suffered some of the worst fires we've
ever seen at least that's what I was
told while spending time in the free
state of Montana they didn't have a Four
Seasons or a Ritz there but that's okay
I thrive through adversity but lately
I'm stressing bro about Florida Governor
DeSantis why is everyone moving there
sure the economy is booming but let me
tell you what Florida does not have
homeless camps in California the biggest
and the best abortion clinics everywhere
just like voting in California you can
do it often early and late really late
and hey Florida certainly doesn't offer
the fresh smell of human feces in the
air or the spectacular site of heroin
needles scattered on sidewalks Florida
doesn't even have an income tax like we
do taking all kinds of your money I say
that's the California way and I've been
inspired by the courage and resilience
of Californians keep it up I'll take
more of your money shut the state down
again and keep tweeting like a 15 year
old at Rhonda Santos while I pursue my
real dream to run for president and make
all of America as awful as California
legal and idiot disclaimer this is not
Kevin newson's voice
okay I feel better I feel better that
was done by my buddy Trey Radell who's a
former Congressman of Southwest Florida
we've had Trey on the show a couple
times he's down in the Fort Myers area
right now really helping with the
Reconstruction over there anyway the way
these lies just keep going man I do feel
better the way these lies just keep
going and they keep going and going and
going and they work their way through
the entire system so here's a tweet by
Joe Biden before we show the Tweet
though you must understand Joe Biden is
not allowed to hold a phone there is
zero chance that they let Joe Biden hold
a phone or have access to Twitter or
literally anything else okay I am
surprised that they don't have someone
else chewing his food at this point but
here's a tweet by Joe Biden related to
exactly what we're talking about here I
think every kid in every zip code in
every state should have access to every
education opportunity possible I guess
for some that is in consensus view this
is a complete Distortion and reverse of
the truth the Democrats and you Joe
Biden you're against school choice it is
now becoming policy of of many
Republicans school choice fund students
not systems it's happening in Iowa it's
happening in Arkansas in Florida we've
removed a lot of the woke stuff out
there still work to do but it's
happening here do not pretend you are
for choice or for good education because
if you were you would want a parent
a young black mom and I know you love to
Pander to black people so you would want
that young black mother not to have to
send her son to the failing school but
she would get some sort of credit this
is if you believe the government has any
role in anything which I'm not really
sure anymore but if you believe the
government has any role in anything and
should tax right then that you could
take the money you could give it to the
mother and she could go okay there's
there's five schools here there's a
little bit more of a distance here but I
can use some of the money to do and
we're going to send them to a better
school and that competition would make
for a better education but just like
Kamala Harris you cannot say anything
true they just can't and you know why
they also can't say anything true
because DeSantis isn't giving them what
they want he is responding to these
clowns perfectly which is basically by
not responding at all
we're here in Duval County we have seen
bookshelves in schools emptied in
response to Florida's new guidelines on
books I'm wondering is this actually you
know that video that was a fake
narrative that was not true and our
press guys where is Brian back there he
can get you the details on that uh this
is trying to create some narrative as if
that they hadn't even put the books out
yet to begin with so there's no need for
all of that stuff what they're trying to
do is they're trying to act like somehow
you know we don't want books the and
some of the narratives that you hear you
hear people talk about felony charges
understand nothing that we've done since
I've been Governor has done anything
that now there is long-standing Florida
law that prohibits an adult from giving
a school child pornography but don't we
think that that's inappropriate to do
but that's been the law for a long time
so when they hear you when you when they
start chirping about that understand
they're talking about long-standing
Florida law that's trying to protect
young children so I think they're trying
to do things to to Virtue signal I think
it's it's all politically motivated but
what the Department of Education I've
asked them I said talk to these school
districts so are there books that that
are problematic are you really removing
and make them justify what they're doing
because I can tell you with our
curriculum transparency parents are
concerned if you have in sixth grade the
ability to access a book that has
pornographic acts depicted and you have
seen that across the country go read
books like genderqueer and see what's in
there it's inappropriate so we've armed
parents the ability to to object to that
and to make sure that they're having
education and not indoctrination but
anytime you hear about something that
seems so outlandish just understand
they're manufacturing that to try to
create a narrative that is the thing
you hear this and it is a manufactured
narrative do you think I would sit here
and defend this guy or defend the state
if they were really coming after books
really coming after books but we all
know that in essence you should not be
giving kids porn at a public school you
shouldn't be giving kids porn how about
that how about that it's just a blanket
statement but this is what the left
wants and they are all running cover why
is Andrea Mitchell running cover for uh
for these people who want kids to know
how to give hand jobs why is kids giving
handjobs so important to Andrea Mitchell
I don't know Andrea Mitchell somebody
should ask you a question I suppose so
where is Ron DeSantis right now well
actually he is laying out his blueprint
for a better America and this morning he
got to New York and he's in New York
right now and he's not just talking
about the education stuff he's talking
about how the blue States and
particularly the blue cities are really
struggling when it comes to policing uh
so let's uh we got some info from the
daily wire on exactly what he's doing
right now Florida Governor Rod DeSantis
is advocating for breaking up the
Federal government's heavy presence in
Washington D.C by moving agencies across
the country we'll get to what I was
referring to in just a sec the
Republican who's widely considered a GOP
front-runner should he enter the 2024
presidential contest provided a glimpse
of his vision for the country too much
power has accumulated in DC and the
result is a detached administrative
state that rules over us and imposes its
will on us DeSantis said while there are
a host of things that need to be done to
reconstitute tuitionalized government
parceling out federal agencies to other
parts of the country could help reduce
the negative effects of this
accumulation of power I don't promise
things I can't deliver to Santa said
which the publication noted was in
reference to his efforts to keep woke
topics out of schools virtually every
major institution in our country is
attempting to impose a progressive
agenda on society descent has said
Florida strives to protect the ability
of its citizens to live their lives free
from this agenda being shoved down their
throats in another move hinting at the
governor's future Ambitions DeSantis has
a book titled the courage to be free
Florida's blueprint for America's
survival due for release on February
28th
the Florida blueprint is a simple
formula be willing to lead have the
courage of your convictions deliver for
your constituents and reap the political
rewards he wrote according to an excerpt
published by the New York Post this is a
blueprint for America's Revival we've
shown it can be done and yes that is the
blueprint remember they are all only
doing this because there is one guy at a
political level and he's giving you the
blueprint so it'll hopefully spread that
is just saying enough
enough is enough and that's all we've
been asking for we have been on an on an
unbelievably vicious brutal painful
slide for a couple years now it has led
to all of this Insanity where you
literally have the president of the
United States pretending to tweet
because there's some guy in Florida who
doesn't want porn in fifth grade
classrooms and
anyway it continues because not only is
DeSantis getting hit from from the left
but he's even getting hit from the right
now and this kind of shows you when
you're over the target you're going to
get it from everybody uh here's a tweet
by Carrie Lake Harry Lake of course I've
had Carrie on the show I consider myself
friendly and myself friendly with her
she was the gubernatorial candidate in
Arizona who lost she's still contesting
the election but she tweeted this out
the kiss of death Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis endorsed by George Soros
um I watched the video and uh no George
Soros did not endorse Ron DeSantis I
actually tweeted at her saying you might
want to review it again but Ann Coulter
Ann Coulter who was a huge Trump person
the first time around who basically is
now anti-trump Ann Coulter was on Tim
Poole's show discussing uh this move by
Carrie Lake and this video basically
where they made it seem like uh Soros
was uh going after Trump and and
endorsing to Santos this one pissed me
off Newsweek writes George Soros prays
for Rhonda Santos rattles Trump
supporters and that's putting it lightly
I saw Gateway pundit wrote George the
kiss of death George Soros endorses
Rhonda Santos which he did not do let me
show you the quote because they actually
do have the quote in here quote DeSantis
is shrewd ruthless and ambitious he is
likely to be the Republican candidate
this could induce Trump whose narcissism
has turned into a disease to run as a
third party candidate that would lead to
a democratic Landslide enforce the
Republican party to reform itself fake
news from Anne I just think it's stupid
to decide whether you like a politician
or a person based on who else likes that
person or doesn't like that person yes
so obviously Soros isn't backing to
santis obviously he might be saying some
actually quasi-truths related to what
Trump's move might be and wouldn't it be
and this is the irony of sort of
unfortunately what seems to be happening
to Trump right now again I like that guy
I like his kids there's a situation I'd
vote for him again I proudly voted for
him last time but this move where he's
so all in on trying to take out DeSantis
right now and putting out all of this
nonsense on Truth social about DeSantis
and by the way it's not working I mean
it's simply not working
um maybe the move is that really and
this would be the ultimate swamp move
for the guy who wants to drain the swamp
is that he will basically start a third
party after this his America first party
and basically destroy the Republican
party so this Democrats can always be in
power wouldn't that be some way of the
swamp actually using Donald Trump I mean
3D chess 5D chess 8D chess you got to
think about these things uh anyway here
is uh just uh sorry here's Coulter
on why she has sort of shifted towards
the DeSantis Camp away from the Trump
Camp Americans were correct to vote for
the guy no matter how much of a
Despicable moronic grifting human being
he was he promised us a wall and that's
why people voted is DeSantis going to
get us a wall
um what I like I think so I think so I
think so I absolutely do and the reason
I say with that enthusiasm is what I
like about
DeSantis is Trump was all talk no action
DeSantis is no talk
yeah
okay so you really have to understand
this this is super super interesting Ann
Coulter she was basically Trump's
biggest intellectual backer right like
she really was I mean this is someone
who crosses it's not that she crosses
the aisle in terms of her intellect but
she crosses the island that she used to
go on Real Time with Bill Maher all the
time they'd disagree on everything I
don't know that she's been on in quite
some time but the point is she's she's
someone that is known around the country
that that five years ago six years ago
when when nobody was willing to touch
Trump just as it was bubbling up she was
one of the first people in on Trump
she's been sorely disappointed mostly
because of the wall situation so that's
her opinion on that which I thought was
interesting and here's here's some of
the things that Trump is doing on Truth
social right now uh this is from a
couple days ago Ron de sanctimonious
wants to cut your Social Security and
Medicare closed up Florida and its
beaches loves rhinos Paul Ryan Jeb Bush
and Karl Rove disasters all is backed by
globalist club for no growth Lincoln
pervert project and uninspired Coke and
it only gets worse from there he has a
rhino in Disguise whose poll numbers are
dropping Like a Rock hold on just leave
it up there so I can go through this
quickly I have never heard Ron DeSantis
say anything related to cutting Social
Security and Medicare I think there
actually are some discussions that we
could honestly have about doing some of
that that they've become too big and
there aren't enough people paying in
anymore and what that would mean closed
up Florida and its beaches uh he did
that for about two weeks and then
reversed on all that Trump actually did
Operation warp speed and even just
months ago was still people telling
people to get Jabs and also when Georgia
tried to open up Trump tried to stop
them loves rhinos Paul Ryan Jeb Bush and
Carl roeb well it's interesting because
Trump you twice endorsed Ron DeSantis so
what does that say about you uh backed
by globalist club for no growth Lincoln
perver project so the Lincoln project
which is a bunch of anti-trump trash
they're all going in on after DeSantis
now so that's just not true uh he's a
rhino in disguise
a rhino in disguise
he's literally doing everything any of
us have asked and if that's all you got
Trump
right like I'm not a cult member that's
the thing like again I like you for the
most part but if this is what you're
gonna do and also this Rhonda
sanctimonious thing which is not picking
up any steam do you know what the
definition of sanctimonious is it's
making a show of being morally Superior
to other people does that seem like what
DeSantis is doing DeSantis literally
stands there and goes stop
stop with the woke stop abusing
citizens stop telling people how to live
does that seem sanctimonious or does
that seem actually the reverse of
sanctimony a sanctimony of being morally
better than everybody well you Trump
turn on everybody everybody that you
hire turns out to be the worst person
possible because you're morally better
than them and you can you know it's like
and again
you got it you guys got it but the point
is the entire machine is going after
DeSantis right now and that tells you
something the machine is not going after
Trump you I am mark my words I have said
it before and I'll say it again you are
going to see MSNBC and CNN and the New
York Times They are all going to become
pro-trump because they know Trump will
never be president and they will use
Trump to destroy DeSantis and if Trump
doesn't see that
well he should see that and Donald Mr
former president I would be GL I will
come to Mar-A-Lago to talk to you about
it if you'd like to off camera if you
want to do that uh but anyway he is just
now we can get to what I referenced
earlier DeSantis is in New York today
because he is trying to show other
states
that there is a blueprint from uh there
is a blueprint for Success so the
governor's office released a press
release right before we went live on air
we're going to give you just a tiny bit
of it here Law and Order Florida leading
the way and I'm just going to chop that
down just a bit Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis is meeting with law enforcement
officers in New York City Philadelphia
and Chicago to share Florida's blueprint
for keeping communities safe and offers
support as blue cities turn their backs
on the law enforcement community Florida
is a refuge for sanity in a world gone
mad Governor Ron DeSantis is leading the
nation to support law enforcement
officers and keep Florida communities
safe the governor has implemented the
most pro-law enforcement policy package
in the country and because of this
Florida is experiencing a 50-year low
crime rate blue cities like New York
City Philadelphia and Chicago are
experiencing a different story due to
failed soft on crime leadership which
endangers their citizens and makes it
harder for law enforcement officers to
do their job and here's just some stats
from some of these places New York City
saw a 23 percent surge in major crimes
in the year 2022 in 2022 more than 170
000 felony crimes were reported in New
York City the most since 2006 that's up
20 from 2021. the number of shoplifting
complaints surged more than 63 000 in
2022 a 45 jump over the roughly 45 000
reported in 2021 and a nearly 275
percent jump compared to the mid-2000s
the statistics show just a little bit
more here in Philadelphia more than 500
citizens were victims of homicides
annually in both 2021 and 2022 under
district attorney Larry casner a murder
rate not seen since 1990. as of February
16 2023 there have been 58 homicides
this past year there were 562 homicides
in Philadelphia in 2021 an increase of
78 percent from the 315 that incurred
that occurred the year before krasner
took office in 2017. 2021 ends and hears
more from Chicago 2021 ends as Chicago's
deadliest year in a quarter Century with
800 homicides total crime in Chicago
went up 41 in 2022 compared to 2021 when
looking at police statistics crime rates
are up 33 percent in since 2019 since
Lori Lightfoot took office and now let's
contrast that with Florida Florida's
crime rate is at a 50-year low according
to the 2021 annual Uniform Crime Report
murder was down 14 robbery was down 17.5
percent aggravated assault was down 1.6
percent burglary was down 15 larceny was
down nearly nine percent motor vehicle
theft was also down 6.4 percent domestic
violence increa decreased by 2.5 percent
Governor DeSantis enacted the most
pro-law enforcement policy package in
the nation in April of 20
. that's a lot of reading people but I
think you get the point the blueprint is
here the facts are the facts and reality
is reality so we will all have to choose
do you want to be San Francisco or do
you want to be Miami do you want to be
capitalist or do you want to be
communist we can make all of these
decisions and just watch the entire
machine be it left or right be it
corporate
it is coming for the guy and we have to
offer a bit of Defense on that it is and
again I'm saying this all without any I
swear to you I have no Insider knowledge
as to whether the guy wants to run or
not it does seem like it's shaping up
that way and that's why the machine is
freaking out and he clearly you know
there's a reason that you'd go and as
the governor of Florida and talk about
crime in New York and Philly and Chicago
there you know that that does give a
hint that there's a national aspiration
here
um but this is this is basically our
last chance this is basically our last
chance and as I said last week as a
Floridian there is part of me that does
not want it to happen it is a huge part
of me because it is so freaking good
here and you'd have to replicate that
with someone else and I don't know
exactly who's on the bench I think there
are some capable people for sure uh but
all of this is action from Ron DeSantis
who isn't even president doing things at
a national level by the way you know
where Joe Biden is we showed it in the
uh
do we oh no we showed it in that Don
Lemon clip uh Joe Biden made a surprise
announcement and uh showed up in Ukraine
today so he's basically president of
Ukraine oddly has not been to East
Palestine yet but uh did show up to
Ukraine we've given them about a hundred
billion dollars I'm fairly certain the
people about East Palestine could have
used that money uh and here is Ron
DeSantis uh respond oh no do we have we
have the other clip first right uh so
here's Ron DeSantis this morning I
believe this is from New York I think
even more important because like as much
as I'm proud that Florida is doing well
I want the country to do well I want all
of these communities to do well
and in order to do that we've got to get
a re Rego a commitment for Law and Order
throughout every corner of this country
in Florida we say uh we fight the woke
and the schools we fight the woke and
the legislature and yes we fight the
woke when they go after our law
enforcement we do not surrender to the
woke mob our state is where woke goes to
die thank you all God bless thanks
I think that's the message people are
starving for we've had enough of the
woke we want competency we want decency
we want honesty uh and we want leaders
who will just do the right thing and at
the moment all you got to do is say
enough so will he run we played you this
clip last week but uh well we shall see
[Applause]
we shall see I'm actually doing an event
on Thursday no I believe Friday with the
governor it is a Florida blueprint event
and this blueprint you know as he talked
about they're they're Blueprinting this
thing across uh Industries basically
it's not just about Blueprinting it on
the policing level but in the education
level virtually every level there's a
blooper in a Florida blueprint
conference going on uh that I'll be
doing something with the governor and I
believe the first lady as well on Friday
so there is good things happening here
and that's that Beacon that you got to
look to like don't think it's all just
terrible for as frustrated as I was with
these crazy lunatics today like really
these really dishonest forces that's
what you would say it's not just
dishonest people it's dishonest forces
that are at work and that's why Don
Lemon you gotta go man you gotta go I
don't care where you go but you can't
stay here and I mean that in Florida
leave Florida please lemon and and
Andrea Mitchell you should be fired and
I'm gonna do what I can to make sure
that you're fired I'm going to keep
pushing this you're a propagandist like
Andrea Mitchell if you because these are
the same people guys you know this they
call all of us misinformation
Specialists right we're the Liars we're
the frauds and all of those things well
Andrea Mitchell you're either a fraud or
an idiot I'd like to figure out which
one so whether it's Don Lemon or Andrea
Mitchell or Joy Reed or Chuck Todd or
Larry Hogan or Gavin Newsom or dare I
say Carrie lake or Donald Trump enough
of the dishonest drivel we have all had
enough
speaking of dishonest dribble it's me
Monday over at the Reuben Port locals
community and I posted Miss Greta
thundberg enjoying a little bit of
everything she has put on some weight uh
Greta she really has you know what I
mean you'd think she would whatever
as we got a post game show for you it's
going to be a doozy if you have not
joined us yet please do it
reubenreport.locals.com
I need a little water we'll be there in
just a sec join us all right see you
tomorrow bye takes us one supportive
adult to make all the difference for an
lgbtqi plus youth uh transgender youth
in terms of their risk of depression and
suicide one supportive adult that often
is a teacher or some a school personnel
and the don't say gay bill is very
damaging to their health
[Music]